sont les évolutions des modes de travail
les plus importants notamment en termes
d'impact sur la la relation de travail
c'est une question qui est effectivement
à la fois essentiel et à partir de
laquelle beaucoup de nouveaux enjeux en
découlent
l'avenir du travail d'ailleurs était le
thème central de la conférence de l'oit
et en 2019 la dernière fois où nous
avons pu tenir une conférence
je dirais physique puisque 2020 il n'y a
pas eu de conférence du tout et en ce
moment se tient une conférence mondiale
sous une forme virtuelle je crains que
la qualité des travaux sans s'en
ressentent mais donc l'avenir du travail
c'était le sujet central du débat
mondial il y a deux ans est ce que je
retiens personnellement garde
naturellement beaucoup d'aspects mais
c'est que le le développement du
commerce internationale conjuguée à
l'impact des nouvelles technologies et
sans doute à la fois le défi principal
mais aussi la source des principaux
bouleversements qui nécessite de
nouvelles réponses sur le terrain du
droit social et au delà est
naturellement législateur peut être
interpellé
à ce propos il est aussi évident dès
lors que l'on réfléchit au devenir du
travail que le défi environnemental
apporte lui aussi de nouvelles approches
sur le contenu des productions sur la
manière de faire du commerce
un sujet qui préoccupe d'ailleurs de
plus en plus les jeunes générations
puisqu'elle pose la question tout
simplement de la finalité du travail du
sens du travail
les évolutions des modes de travail sont
principalement la résultante d'une
pression à l'international qui s'accroît
sur la base du dumping social
naturellement du point de vue d'un
représentant des travailleurs cela ne
vous surprendra pas que je mette cet
aspect en exergue 60% des emplois dans
le monde actuellement sont dans
l'économie informelle
c'est à dire l'économie qui ne paie ni
impôts ni taxes ni cotisations sociales
six emplois sur 10 dans le monde sont
dans l'économie informelle
ce chiffre est naturellement un chiffre
validé
officiel de l'organisation
internationale du travail et donc validé
par ses trois composantes que sont les
représentants des différents états les
représentants des employeurs de ces pays
et les représentants des travailleurs
alors on peut naturellement toujours
débattre des raisons qui font que l'on
atteint de tels niveaux de travail
informel dans le monde mais le chiffre
lui est incontestable avec des
conséquences très directe 65 % des
travailleurs à l'heure actuelle n'ont
pas de véritable système de protection
sociale et près d'un sur deux n'a aucune
assurance maladie et vous imaginez les
répercussions dans cette période de
pandémie
ce qui explique que dans nombre de pays
malgré tout les restrictions apportées
de un grand nombre de travailleurs n'a
pas d'autre choix que d'essayer de
travailler malgré tout dans la mesure où
bas c'est le seul moyen d'assurer un
minimum de ressources pour vivre et
faire vivre sa famille un emploi sur
cinq
je donne quelques autres données pour
bien situer l'environnement plus global
dans lequel nos nos réflexions
s'inscrivent un emploi sur cinq
aujourd'hui dépend de la stratégie de
80000 multinationales un emploi sur cinq
est là la france n'échappe pas à cette
géographie international 80000
multinationales là aussi c'est le
chiffre de référence on pourrait
naturellement tout dépend en mots situe
la barre en termes de soi de chiffre
d'affaires d'effectifs etc
mais on s'accorde pour débattre autour
de ce chiffre de référence de 80000 ce
qu'on appelle les chaînes de l'aveu de
valeur sont à la fois plus international
et contradictoirement emploie
directement très peu de travail 80 mille
entreprises utilisent directement 250
millions de salariés le reste est en
sous traitance donc ce un emploi sur
cinq très souvent n'est pas un emploi
direct qui lit celui qui produit et
celui qui commercent il ya le phénomène
de sous traitance qui qui s'amplifie et
de ce point de vue là l'impact des
nouvelles technologies est aussi un
impact considérable
on pourrait revenir les relations d'un
nerd hors sous-traitants se font de plus
en plus pressantes sur la notion de coût
dont le coût social et vous comprenez
bien que dès lors que dans la majorité
des emplois du monde c'est l'absence de
droits élémentaires
cette pression s'exerce notamment
l'égard d'un pays comme la france sur la
base des droits sociaux qui sont mis en
corrélation en comparaison avec ceux qui
n'en n'ont quasiment pas et dans ce
cadre le phénomène se trouve amplifié
par certains usages des nouvelles
capacités technologiques et comme toute
technologie ce n'est pas un constat
spécifique aux problématiques liées au
travail
l'usagé technologie l'appréciation qu'on
peut en faire varie naturellement de
l'usaj que l'on veut bien faire d'une
technologie qui peut avoir d'énormes
atouts représenter des avancées y
compris pour le bien-être dans de
multiples domaines mersey qu'aussi une
même technologie peut être à revers
utilisé au détriment soin de la santé de
la sécurité peu importe du bien-être
social
donc il en va du travail et des
nouvelles technologies liées au travail
comme sur les autres technologies
suivant l'usagé que l'on en fait cela
peut apporter à un plus je dirais
qualitatif voir quantitatif ou au
contraire être source de nouvelles
dérives sur laquelle peut être il
conviendrait de modifier ou de faire
évoluer le droit qui n'avaient pas
forcément intégrer ces nouvelles formes
de travail donc je prend ainsi le cas du
télétravail pour vous en dire un mot qui
s'est fortement développée notamment
sous la contrainte naturellement de
cette pandémie mondiale
de ce point de vue là je vous invite à
prendre connaissance du guide pratique
qui a été édité par l'organisation
internationale du travail en octobre
2020 qui donne des orientations des
recommandations sur l'utilisation du
télétravail durant la pandémie mais et
après et ce qui est intéressant en tout
cas il faut le souhaiter
c'est qu'on s'approche de cette notion
de la presse et le télétravail dans ce
dans ce guide et est mis en avant comme
pouvant représenter des opportunités
nouvelles je vais citer un seul exemple
par exemple il est notable que les
personnels subissant un handicap qui ont
en général plus de difficultés pour
accéder au travail pour de multiples
raisons ont pu voir des capacités
professionnelles s'élargir avec le
télétravail ce qui n'était pas le cas
auparavant donc on voit que dans ce cas
là et il y en ad'autres le télétravail a
pu être un plus mais on peut aborder
j'imagine que vous le faites également
toute la problématique de la conjugaison
temps de travail temps personnel avec de
nouvelles organisations à la fois
professionnelles mais aussi personnelles
mais remettent dans le même temps le
télétravail est source de dérives
au regard du droit social et dans le
rapport qui a produit l'oit et sur
l'analyse de l'impact du télétravail en
2020 donc c'est encore partiels dans
cette période de pandémie on est en
demies le maintien il ya deux dérives
principal que je voulais évoquer auprès
de vous d'une part le télétravail a
augmenté le travail non déclaré
donc je vous ai dit qu'on était déjà à
60% et vous comprenez bien que c'est une
source d'inquiétude donc le télétravail
a pu augmenter le travail non déclaré et
le télétravail à augmenter le temps de
travail
ça c'est une tendance internationale
constaté le temps de travail pour les
travailleurs avec une confusion qui
s'entretient entre temps de travail et
temps de repos alors en france il ya eu
cette négociation interprofessionnelle
sur le télétravail
elle n'a pas débouché sur un accord
interprofessionnel permettant de définir
les conditions d'exercice du télétravail
en france mais sur une sorte de guide de
bonnes pratiques en quelque sorte
laissant ainsi aux entreprises aux
employeurs le soin de s'en inspirer
ou pas et cela illustre de mon point de
vue une nouvelle fois une une rupture
avec la structure du droit social
français qui est qui a été entamée
depuis plusieurs décennies maintenant ce
n'est pas un phénomène nouveau mais je
voulais m'y arrêter un instant près nous
parce que ce qui est ce que soulève ce
saut l'ismans selon moi c'est tout
simplement la problématique de savoir
quels qu'ils allaient spa souhaite
occuper le droit social collectif et
donc éventuellement la loi ou les textes
référent et ce qui doit être laissée à
la libre appréciation soit entreprise
par entreprise soit branches
professionnelles par branche
professionnelle
on peut là aussi avoir des avoirs les
variables et de nouveau cette
problématique du télétravail
des mouches sur aussi le risque lune et
inégalité de traitement de salariés qui
peuvent être à situation comparable mais
qui suivant l'entreprise dans laquelle
ils travaillent vont pouvoir se
s'accorder sur des modalités qui peuvent
être très différentes d'un salarié à un
autre ce qui n'est pas sans soulever de
mon point de vue des questions liées à
aux inégalités de plus en plus
importante vis-à-vis du droit du travail
en fonction de l'entreprise dans
laquelle on exerce son activité et à cet
égard
j'aurais rappeler que la france est l'un
des pays du monde où le taux d des
conventions de couverture des salariés
par les conventions collectives est le
plus élevé on doit être les premiers
avec l'autriche de ce point de vue là
est le principe même de la convention
collective repose sur le principe de
l'égalité de traitement au sens large du
terme je ne parle pas que du traitement
de la rémunération du traitement social
au sens large du terme
une égalité de traitement entre
travailleurs aux activités comparables
par exemple dans une branche
professionnelle afin de considérer que
dans la compétition économique entre les
entreprises il y avait plusieurs
facteurs de compétitivité qui était
naturellement possible et respectable
les capacités de recherche de mise au
point de développement les capacités à
communiquer sur les sur ses produits et
les capacités de communication mais la
convention collective revient à dire
qu'on ne considère pas que les
conditions sociales différentes d'une
entreprise à une autre dans un même
secteur doivent être des éléments de
compétitivité sinon on prend le risque
d'une forme de dumping social c'est ce à
l'origine des conventions collectives
dans notre pays dont je rappelle que
l'origine vient de d'action syndicale
sociale dans les mines du nord de la
france c'est ça notre c'est ça notre
histoire et on a même été jusqu'à
considérer et certains nous l'envient ô
combien j'en suis témoin dans cette
halle de pandémie que sur les questions
de protection sociale il nous fallait un
dispositif qu'ils soient collectifs avec
un accès généralisé ces principes
de la sécurité sociale dont on ne peut
que se féliciter dans une période comme
celle ci je ne développerai pas sur les
témoignages de mes camarades qui sont
dans des pays n'ayant pas du tout de
systèmes comparables ou avoisinants et
donc ce principe d'un d'égalité vis à
vis du droit du travail a été très
déstabilisée par des réformes
successives sur le droit du travail
c'est la décentralisation de la
négociation collective de plus en plus
entreprise par entreprise
l'affaiblissement des instruments de
représentation collective des
travailleurs et de ce point de vue là
l'instauration des c est ce en
substitution des délégués du personnel
comité d'entreprise comité d'hygiène et
de sécurité n'a pas forcément été une
bonne opération de mon point de vue et
on voit d'ailleurs qu'en termes de
représentation les nouvelles
technologies posent des questions
similaires mais sa hausse était aussi la
multiplication des formes de contrats de
travail et de ce point de vue là de
nouveau sous l'impact de l'apparition de
nouvelles technologies on voir émerger
des débats quant à la nécessité
éventuelle mans d'innover pour instaurer
de nos statuts pour les travailleurs on
n'irait donc à une multiplication encore
une fois de ce genre de situation la
question des plateformes sur lequel je
vais revenir un instant l'illustrent ô
combien nous sommes ainsi dans un
paradoxe majeur de mon point de vue qui
est susceptible de provoquer de graves
tensions à l'avenir sur le plan social
d'un côté une économie de plus en plus
global avec des règles mondiales des
organismes qui surveillent la bonne
application de ces règles et de l'autre
une tendance à individualiser de plus en
plus le droit social et donc vous voyez
qu'il ya là en quelque sorte un deux
poids deux mesures un déséquilibre alors
naturellement personne n'imagine et à
l'eau était pas plus qu'ailleurs que le
droit social peut être uniforme à
l'échelle mondiale ce n'est pas du tout
mais il ya un certain nombre de
principes de droits fondamentaux qu'il
nous faudrait faire progresser quel que
soit
les points du globe et vous connaissez
je vous rappellerai pas là la liste des
droits fondamentaux considéré par par
l'oit et est donc cette tendance à
individualiser de plus en plus le droit
social des travailleurs est souvent
présenté au nom de la liberté
individuelle ou d'une certaine modernité
or
pardonnez moi de rappeler aux
législateurs mais il ya une évidence il
n'y a pas de liberté individuelle sans
droits collectifs ça n'existe pas et
dans tous les domaines et naturellement
c'est au législateur qu'il appartient de
définir ce qu'il convient d'arrêter
comme un droit collectif quitte à ce que
les modalités d'application puissent
elles être variable
compte tenu des situations spécifiques
et de ce point de vue là le droit social
a toujours su tenir compte de
spécificités je pense au travail
saisonnier je pense le tout étant que ce
soit le résultat d'une réelle
négociation entre les différents acteurs
de manière à ce qu'ils aient pas le
sentiment d'un d'un préjudice ou d'un
mauvais traitements du côté des du côté
des salariés alors quelques mots sur
vous m'arrêtez un seul président si vous
considérez je suis un peu trop long sur
mon propos je voulais évoquer la
problématique donc des plateformes
numériques objet de vaud de vos travaux
également l'oit et a publié hier à 12h
très précisément un nouveau rapport sur
les questions d'emploi et questions
sociales dans le monde
bon je ne reprends pas l'essentiel de
ceux de ce rapport si ce n'est pour dire
que les projections annoncées en matière
d'emploi sont particulièrement sombres
pour la période à venir avec au delà du
nombre d'emplois susceptibles d'être
disponible une
une large aggravation des inégalités et
de la précarité qui semble être se
dessiner si naturellement les états et
de manière coordonnée ne trouve pas les
voies et les moyens pour réagir en
conséquence ce qui est quand même un
pronostic est assez sombre de notre
point de vue est particulièrement
inquiétant mais dans sept danseurs dans
ce rapport sur les questions sociales
dans le monde dans la période à venir
une partie a été publiée auparavant sur
le rôle des plateformes numériques dans
la transformation du monde du travail
donc ses taux au centre je pense de vos
nouveaux réflexion ou parmi vos
réflexions
c'est une enquête et il a aussi à une
publication donc je vous invite
éventuellement à en prendre connaissance
in extenso c'est une enquête qui repose
sur l'étude de la situation de 85
entreprises réparties dans le monde dont
85 plates formes différentes
première donnée en dix ans le nombre de
plateformes a été multiplié par cinq et
les projections laisse entendre que ça
va continuer de se développer et dans
des domaines
qu'on ne soupçonne peut être pas
aujourd'hui mais que l'on voit poindre
donc c'est un sujet d'actualité et qui
nécessite comme vous le fait d'y
travailler
s'agissant des investissements dans ce
domaine il est noté que 96% des
investissements se concentrent en asie
en amérique du nord et en europe
par contre il attire votre attention sur
le fait que s'agissant des revenus prêts
issus de l'activité de ces plateformes
70% des revenus se concentrent dans deux
pays seulement les états unis et la
chine donc je les bocks tout simplement
pour sensibiliser sur le fait que si
d'aucuns pensent qu'il ya là un nouvel
eldorado économique aujourd'hui voilà
les concentrations sont déjà assez assez
manifeste alors l'oit et appelle à une
concertation politique internationale et
à une coopération dans le domaine de la
réglementation des plateformes
mais comme dans tout domaine et vous le
vous le savez bien
n'attendons pas que le droit
international ou ne cossu neuneu
conditionnons pas plutôt l'évolution de
notre droit national à une avancée
international je suis bien placé pour
savoir que c'est en général beaucoup
plus long donc beaucoup plus laborieux
et que parfois et souvent même le droit
international s'inspire de droits
nationaux qui peuvent être source de
référence pour une législation qui
s'étend sur un continent en europe par
exemple ou plus largement donc tous les
travaux permettant d'avancer dans ce
domaine seront les bienvenus les défis
sur les plateformes ont été identifiés
par l'oit et sur ceux sur ce rapport
encore une fois c'est un extrait très
imparfait
les défis auxquels font face les
travailleurs de ces plateformes concerne
aussi bien les conditions de travail la
régularité du travail et des revenus
l'absence d'accès à la protection
sociale et j'ai noté que vous en aviez
fait un sujet de préoccupation les
horaires de travail
naturellement qui peuvent s'avérer à la
fois long et imprévisible la moitié
aujourd'hui des travailleurs des
plateformes gagne moins de deux dollars
us de l'heure se voit là la monnaie de
référence dans les institutions
internationales on raisonne en dollars
us et avec y compris les pratiques
d'écarts de salaires qui sont basées sur
le genre avec des plateformes qui
parfois ne rémunérera pas forcément au
même niveau hommes et femmes exerçant la
même la même activité
et côté entreprise il ya aussi de
nombreuses entreprises qui font face à
des problèmes de concurrence déloyale
dans ce domaine une absence de
transparence sur les données les prix
les commissions élevées et avec des
également des problèmes d'accès au
financement et aux infrastructures
numériques
une phrase à propos de pour résumer un
peu l'état d'esprit de l'oit et je
reprends la une phrase le directeur
général de l'oit et quand la publication
en février de ce rapport sur les plates
formes a été présentée tous les
travailleurs dit-il quel que soit leur
statut professionnel doivent être en
mesure d'exercer leurs droits
fondamentaux au travail alors les
modalités là aussi peuvent être
différentes de ce point de vue là à la
fois les statuts juridiques de ces
entreprises mais aussi fait aux
travailleurs est variable d'un pays à un
autre vous le savez bien avec des
polémiques mais ce sont des polémiques
je dirai tout à fait légitime entre
mouvement syndical employeurs certains
états parfois et tribunaux qui peuvent
prendre aussi d'aider
décision brrr contradictoires et nous
sommes je dirais si j'ai bien compris en
france un peu entre deux eaux à essayer
d'installer un statut un peu un peu
hybride
en tout cas je retiens que le choix
politique consiste au stade actuel ne
pas considérer qu'on a affaire là un
travail qui pourrait s'apparenter au
salariat classique et donc il faudrait
innover imaginer un statut un peu un peu
hybride alors sur les plates formes
encore un mot voulait peut-être aussi
constaté un article de presse la presse
du soir comme selon la formule consacrée
on faisait et à l'utilisation des
plateformes va se généraliser dans
maints domaines
on est en train de constater par exemple
c'est l'objet de cet article mais il ya
d'autres exemples des plates formes
d'emploi aujourd'hui qui sont des
supports qui permettent d' homme mon
point de vue des abus un contournement
du droit social puisque ces plates
formes d'emplois suggère notamment que
tous ceux qui étaient salariés où un
certain nombre de ceux qui étaient
salariés hier conserve la même activité
professionnelle mais change de statut en
passant à auto entrepreneurs on a là une
déviation du droit social qui a aussi
des conséquences
j'évoquais d'un système de sécurité
sociale est naturellement vous y êtes
vous y êtes sensibles si on a une partie
importante du travail qui change de
statut sans continuer à contribuer à ce
bien public qu'est la sécurité sociale
le système de protection sociale
s'effondre c'est pas la peine de d'aller
chercher midi à quatorze heures
il n'est pas sans soulever des
problématiques sur la pérennité de son
fou de ce refinancement et c est tout ça
soulève là aussi des débats tout à fait
légitime mais on sait socle c'est d'en
faire un système qui soit collectif est
donc obligatoire avec une obligation de
cotisation est tentant luc naturellement
ce niveau et ses modalités de cotisation
sont objet de débat permanent ça ce
n'est pas en cause mais si on extrait
naturellement une partie importante de
la main d'oeuvre en france de ce système
de protection collective voilà alors
après on est obligé de s'interroger sur
comment faire pour que ceux qui ne
cotisent pas ce système collectif puisse
malgré tout avoir une protection sociale
enfin on est en aidant 1
on est là dans un je dirais un peu une
position schizophrène 1 alors dernier
mot monsieur le président je m'excuse
auprès d'auger jeu convient d'être
tahoua est excessivement longs en
préparant quelques notes on n'a pas
forcément conscience du temps que l'on
que l'on peut passer à développer son
propos mais pour dire en guise de
conclusion que selon l'oit et 80% du
travail à l'avenir continuera de se
faire pour autrui autrement dit dans la
grande majorité des cas on continuera de
travailler pour quelqu'un d'autre alors
ça peut être que quelqu'un d'autre ça
peut être un particulier ça peut être
une entreprise mais on travaillera pour
quelqu'un d'autre alors là aussi ça
n'empêche pas d'avoir le débat sur la
nature de la relation
mais dans la grande majorité des cas
selon l'oit et ça restera dans un
rapport salarial c'est à dire un
recrutement et est donc la question de
l'évolution du droit du travail demeure
une question tout à fait pertinente et
non pas dépasser lorsque j'entends
certains observateurs ou
[Musique]
aux gens qui veulent proposer des
schémas d'avenir considérer que le
salariat serait une notion dépassée
auquel il faudrait lui substituer
d'autres d'autres statues en tout cas je
voulais conclure par ce par ce constat
que pour le rite et ce n'était
absolument pas une une réalité
et puis derrière toute fin de citation
c'est une phrase de la déclaration de
philadelphie adopté à l'oit et après la
deuxième guerre mondiale selon laquelle
il n'y a pas de paix universelle sans
justice sociale et il faut absolument
faire en sorte que le développement de
cette nouvelle et de ces nouvelles
technologies qui ont un impact encore
une fois sur le travail ne soit pas
synonyme de plus grandes injustices
sociales ou de désert s'agissant des
droits sociaux des des salariés je vous
remercie monsieur le président
m'excusant une nouvelle fois peut-être
la longueur de mon propos merci beaucoup
en tout cas c'est un sujet qui méritait
que vous preniez le temps avec la
passion qu'on vous connaît pour en
parler et la précision surtout donc je
vais donner la parole aux rapporteurs en
commençant par michel canevet et puis
ensuite fabien gay car tous les deux
vont devoir aller en séance puisque ils
interviennent dans rapidement après donc
tout de suite michel canevet merci
monsieur le président je voudrais
remercier aussi notre orateur les
chiffres qu'il a énoncées dans son
propos liminaire montrent bien l'ampleur
du travail qu'il reste encore à réaliser
pour qu'à travers le monde justement on
puisse avoir des systèmes de
fonctionnement qui permettent à ceux qui
travaillent d'avoir la protection
sociale et donc il ya encore beaucoup de
travail à faire il a évoqué également
dans son propos la question des droits
sociaux moi je dis aussi qu'il y allait
devoir sociaux et on peut quand même
s'apercevoir qu'un certain nombre de
deux jambes
beaucoup de jeunes aujourd'hui aspire je
dirais à ne pas être trop dépendant des
devoirs sociaux j'entends par là ne pas
devoir ne pas vous devoir dépendre de
décision il est rare chizy pouvoir
travailler selon à un rythme de deux
vies qu'ils choisissent et donc c'est
peut-être cette défiance
à l'égard des devoirs sociaux qui fait
que peut-être d'autres formes de travail
que le salariat ont tendance à vouloir
être privilégiée aujourd'hui par ces
nouvelles générations qui arrivent il
faut se poser la question est donc je me
dis que peut-être le salarié n'est pas
adapté à l'émergence de nouvelles formes
de travail que bernard thibault a évoqué
tout à l'heure l'ampleur que prennent
le travail autour du numérique
effectivement et les métiers qui demain
seront affectés par ce là ce qui l'a
d'ailleurs quelques suggestions quelques
idées de 2cm de ces évolutions des
métiers on les connaît bien dans ce qui
concerne le transport des personnes ou
de marchandises aujourd'hui mais il ya
beaucoup d'autres perspectives qui
s'établissent effectivement et je
voulais lui demander quand il dit que
80% du travail à la dir se fera pour
autrui est ce que pour autrui c gepa
pour quelqu'un c'est pas forcément pour
une personne est ce que c'est pas pour
plusieurs opérateurs et travaillant pour
plusieurs opérateurs c'est pas forcément
le sentiment de dépendance vis-à-vis
d'une personne mais c'est là aussi un
travail relativement indépendant qui
peut-être émergents en quelque sorte
et puis une petite incidence aussi sur
les questions de protection sociale
effectivement nous sommes très attachés
nous en france à la protection sociale
simplement le problème c'est que le
financement d'une protection sociale qui
est accrue se fait par un alourdissement
du coût du travail qui dans un contexte
d'économie relativement internationaux
esi s'avère pénalisant pour les
entreprises françaises et donc pour
l'ensemble des personnels le français et
est donc il faut qu'on fasse attention à
ce que il n'y a pas une course à
l'échalote par quelque sorte sur la
protection sociale qui conduisent à dire
que à chaque fois que nos arguments des
droits sociaux et c'est légitime
on induit une augmentation des
cotisations sociales qui est aussi
difficile pour un supporter en termes de
compétition économique donc il ya aussi
des facteurs limitants et peut-être
faudra-t-il trouver un autre mode de
financement de la protection sociale que
le seul les seules cotisations sur le
travail à l'avenir
merci j'ai demandé peut-être à la suite
le fait bien si tu veux poser des
questions et puis
d'un article reprendra les les deux
entrées cher bernard on ne va pas faire
semblant
non moi je d'avoir suis très content de
te revoir et est très très heureuse
d'avoir eu ce ce ce propos introductif
qui pour le coup donné une vision
internationale
c'est ça qu'on cherchait et je t'en
remercie notamment les chiffres je
partage que dit michel je ne les avais
pas mais six sur dix dans le travail
informel dans le monde
ça doit quand même nous interroger c'est
pas le cas en france mais mais ça peut
le devenir
voilà moi deux questions je vais pas
faire trop long parce que je pour une
fois je partage plutôt l'avis de
l'orateur ce qui est rare c'est en
conviendra michel je commence toujours
ici revient à un petit différend ou mais
c'est parce que c'est moins le cas dans
deux questions on l'a évoqué hier parce
qu'on s'est vus entre rapporteur et à
madame ou tri et l'ensemble de l'équipe
sur la finalité du rapport on a utile
dit ce que ce soit extrêmement
intéressante au début de notre de notre
de nos premières auditions et à quelques
mois on a beaucoup parlé de la finalité
du travail
ce que tu as évoqué moi je pense que
c'est une vraie question pourquoi on
travaille comment on travaille
pourquoi qu'est ce que je veux faire je
veux être en maîtrise aussi de tous de
comprendre et je veux avoir il est le je
vais être utile y compris à changer la
société de manière éthique de manière
environnementale et c'est une vraie
question qu'on sent poussé dans une
partie de la jeunesse parce que la
question du salaire et de la
rémunération elle est aussi importante
quand même bon il faut vivre de son
travail
mais cette question là elle est elle en
train de pousser donc jouer tut tut tut
là on peut évoquer mais le ans je sais
que c'est complexe là dans le moment de
crise que nous vivons
justement mais je crois que justement il
faut pas lâcher ça parce que si on lâche
au moment de la crise en dix ans quoi
qu'il arrive nous posons pas la question
la finalité est la seule question c'est
il faut que tout le monde travaille
on va avoir un problème profitons la
crise justement pour reposer des bases à
mon avis et ça c'est un débat politique
pour comment on travaille et on est
utile à transformer la société alors
évidemment après n'est pas tous d'accord
comment on veut la transformer mais sur
les questions environnementales
mon travail n'est pas destructeur de la
planète on travaille peut permettre de
sauver la planète par exemple ça c'est
une une question
et puis la deuxième alors je vais les
poser a eu peur et je vais me reposer à
bernard thibault et on l'a vu hier mois
on a un problème sur les plateformes
numériques
beaucoup de groupes ici ont déposé des
propositions de loi il ya eu beaucoup de
choses nous aussi par exemple le là où
tu as raison c'est que déjà dans le code
du travail
il existe on prend tout un tas de
dimensions multiples tu as évoqué le
travail saisonnier mais par exemple dans
le livre celle du code du travail qui
est sur des mannequins et c'est bon on
nous nous avons proposé que ces
travailleurs des plateformes numériques
puisse rentrer dans le livre 7 c'est un
débat ça a été refusé ici il continue
seulement mais moi je repose la question
comment on offre une protection sociale
quand je dis offre comme on donne une
protection sociale sans salaire et sans
cotisation et personne n'est capable de
me répondre sur cette question et donc
oui c'est afs et affaiblir la sécurité
sociale et ça veut dire qu'on passe sur
un système assurantiel mais là on est
sur autre chose
chacun a cotisé pour les reer pour pour
son propre registre celui qui aura un
bon salaire pour y compris ses
plateformes c'est pas un salaire c'est
un revenu pour à cotiser pour ses
propres risques et la mais on change la
société française et notre modèle social
donc là je repose la question est ce que
il ya une idée de comment on offre une
protection sociale sans salaire sans
cotisation voilà je fais pas trop long
pour mercy et il y avait beaucoup
d'autres choses mais tant pis oui et ça
fait du bien mais michel était très
content de ce lait ce propos introductif
will fabien ya beaucoup d'autres choses
évidemment
donc on comprendra bien votre départ
éventuel rapide puisque vous êtes
appelés à intervenir
vous ferez avec ta compréhension je
donne tout de suite la parole à bernard
thibault oui merci monsieur le président
juste une réflexion passage à propos du
travail informel donc parfois on peut
considérer qu'on en serait exonérée en
france je rappelle qu'un rapport du
conseil économique et social il y a deux
trois ans de mémoire avait évalué à peu
près à 8% le pibe français issus du
travail informel est en progrès en
progrès avec des secteurs et ce n'est
pas propre à la france d'ailleurs ces
secteurs dominants sur le travail non
déclaré
l'agriculture le bâtiment la
restauration hôtellerie restauration
tourisme qui se marie un peu avec
hôtellerie-restauration naturellement
voilà les filières internationales
d'ailleurs un et dans ce sens on est pas
on n'est pas protégé on n'est pas exempt
de réflexion à ceux à ce propos alors
les jeunes alors c'est toujours délicat
de classifier des catégories d'âge dans
une globalité
quand on dit les jeunes il ya de
multiples jeux différents a pas
développé mais comme si on disait les
personnes âgées les ou des cas où les
hantent les entreprises les entreprises
voilà une formule qui masque une grande
disparité est donc y voilà les jeunes si
on s'en tient à cette formule 1 sont de
plus en plus éduqués à l'idée qu'il ne
faut plus qu'il s'attache à une seule
entreprise pour leur devenir
on leur explique que le monde économique
étant ce qu'il est les évolutions étant
ce qu'elles sont il faut presque qu'ils
apprennent d'entrée
affaire l'avenir 2 3 métiers différents
en tout cas qui se prépare à ne plus
être lié à un seul employeur durant
toute leur carrière contrairement à
leurs parents leurs grands parents et
cetera et cetera
donc à partir de là on induit d'entrée
le fait que le rapport du jeune salarié
à son entreprise n'est qu'une passe
transitoire c'est en ce sens que il n'y
a pas la même relation avec ce qui est
que commandement de l'entreprise c'est
que on a le sentiment d'être là de
passage
et puis il ya aussi la manière dont les
aînés ont pu être traitées ou en tout
cas dont la jeunesse a pu constater
qu'elles pouvaient être traitées je
pense à des des plans de licenciements
peut-être qu'on ne le retient pas à
cette échelle là mais des plans de
licenciements massifs de personnes qui
ont peut-être passé trente à quarante
ans de leur carrière professionnelle
dans l'entreprise lors gosse lorsqu'il
constate ça se dit mais c'est quand même
un drôle de un drôle d'hommage de la
part d'une entreprise vis-à-vis d'un
salarié qui a consacré toute sa carrière
professionnelle à l'entreprise de se
voir licencier alors moyennant quelques
petites indemnités pour que les choses
bon voilà et donc ça renvoie un rapport
à l'entreprise qui est tout à fait
différente mais par contre moi je pense
que ça ne remet pas pour autant en cause
dont il ya une recherche d'une certaine
liberté en ce sens où le sort des jeunes
générations ne veut pas se voir lire
uniquement à sa relation salariale avec
un employeur parce que ça c'est une
fragilité dont comment faire alors il ya
effectivement la tentation ou la
tendance pour certains à se dire on va
changer de statut dans le rapport on a
pu être dans un rapport salarial
on va être dans un rapport d'une nature
commerciale on va devenir auto
entrepreneur on va être livreur et
j'éprouvais relie vrai lorsque j'aurai
envie je vais pouvoir gérer mes horaires
comme je l'entends sauf que l' usage
c'est pas ça
le travail on recrute quand il ya du
travail à faire le livreur il livre
coach a besoin de livrer c'est pas lui
qui choisit les horaires de repas
il n'a pas livrer des repas à 15 heures
et 16 heures il va livrer des repas
roseraie où il faut livrer des repas et
il en va de même pour les colis avec un
rythme qui s'accélère au détriment y
compris parfois de f1 souvent de la
santé des travailleurs avant-hier il ya
un rapport des syndicats américains il
en existe même si c'est pas facile
d'être syndiqués aux états unis mais il
ya quand même des syndicalistes qui ont
produit un rapport qui montrait et
amazon est obligé de le reconnaître que
la gestion des salariés dans un entrepôt
amazon par un algorithme le travail
aujourd'hui n'est plus organisé par
l'être humain
il est organisé par des algorithmes
avait augmenté les accidents du travail
de 80% par rapport aux autres entrepôts
de même nature qui ne fonctionne pas
avec des algorithmes voilà un autre
exemple de l' usage de la technologie
qui peut enfin qu'il à être utilisé à
des fins vous le propose rien de
productivité mais au détriment de la
santé des individus au combien donc je
pense que c'est c'est là dessus que les
jeunes sont plutôt en recherche de
nouvelles réponses considérant que le
statut salarial ne protège pas
suffisamment ou ou ligotent peut-être
davantage mais ça ne veut pas dire pour
autant que vis-à-vis du système de
protection sociale il soit ils ont soit
détachée ou qu'il veuille s'en éloigner
loin loin s'en faut
je pense loin s'en faut alors quand
j'évoquais effectivement et vous l'avez
repris qui que 80% du travail pour pour
autrui
oui ça peut être pour autrui mais pour
plusieurs autrui plusieurs autres
personnes pour une autre entreprise mais
ça ce n'est pas fondamentalement nouveau
je dirais tu as toujours vous trouvez
dans ma main en activité aujourd'hui
plusieurs types d'employeurs vous prenez
le travail à domicile aujourd'hui les
aides à domicile une aide à domicile
peut travailler sur plusieurs domiciles
ne sait pas donc ça en soit ça n'est pas
la difficulté d'un point de vue social
et on accroît ce genre de situation
c'est vos droits sociaux dépendent de
chacune des situations de relation
salariale en question donc si vous avez
plusieurs employeurs vous additionnez
les droits sociaux et c'est ça je pense
qu est explosif à l'avenir plus on
avance dans le temps avec une
décentralisation des droits qui va
jusqu'à définir des droits en fonction
du poste occupé par l'individu on a une
inégalité de traitement avec de plus en
plus de gens qui passent au travers des
grilles des droits sociaux il n'est pas
normal que de plus en plus de droits
sociaux dépendre de la taille de
l'entreprise dans laquelle vous
travaillez du métier que vous exercez de
l'ancienneté pour partie quoique ça ça
peut se se discuter et naturellement du
niveau de compétition internationale moi
je pense qu'il nous faudrait vous ai
parlé des conventions collectives et
s'ils demeurent dans sa philosophie
première très attaché mais ça ne suffit
même plus la convention collective
aujourd'hui dans la mesure où comme je
vous l'indiquais on explique aux jeunes
générations et il ya des arguments pour
le justifier qu'ils doivent être aussi
en capacité de changer de filière
d'activité
donc il nous faut bien avoir des droits
sociaux qui accompagne le set 7
fluidification du parcours or on
individualise d'épeler droit alors qu'on
demande une fluidification des parcours
c'est là qu'il ya un paradoxe qui de mon
point de vue et est majeur alors vous
comprenez que je ne partage pas
forcément ce que j'ai compris de votre
interprétation sur le coût de la
protection sociale
parce qu'effectivement quand je vous ai
dit que 65 % des travailleurs dans le
monde aujourd'hui ne dispose pas d'un
véritable système de protection sociale
et c'est d'ailleurs l'objet de multiples
débats à l'international comme au plan
national dès lors que l'on parle
compétitivité on compare des choses qui
ne sont pas comparables
on a fait beaucoup beaucoup de cas et
c'est compréhensible de la situation
sanitaire en inde ces dernières semaines
93% du travail en inde est informel 93%
vous ne pouvez pas avoir de système de
santé publique
le système de soins le système de
secours dans un pays qui n'a pas de
système public de protection sociale
publique ou privée après on peut
toujours certains peuvent faire le choix
peu importe mais dès lors que vous ne
contribuez pas au financement d'un
système de protection sociale quel qu'il
soit je dirais vous ne pouvez pas vous
étonner que face à un phénomène aussi
meurtrier que celui là oui mais il ya
une relation en direct alors faut-il et
en ce sens il ya une délibération à
l'oit est alors qu'ils se trouvent un
peu plus un peu c'est du fait de la
pandémie parce qu'elle était elle était
pressée 17 cas de pandémie nous avons
sommes parvenus à faire reconnaître dans
une délibération
jeudi nous parce que c'est à
l'initiative des travailleurs
naturellement que ce sujet là est venu à
à à faire reconnaître qu'à l'avenir la
protection sociale devait faire partie
des droits fondamentaux du travail
alors on est très loin je ne reviens pas
sur les chiffres que je vous ai donné
droits fondamentaux ça veut dire au même
niveau de droits que l'interdiction du
travail des enfants entre l'interdiction
du travail forcé la liberté syndicale
liberté d'association syndicale qui est
loin encore d'être respectés c'est un
droit fondamental mais c'est loin encore
d'être respectés et donc naturellement
pour nous ce serait un point d'appui
considérable pour faire pression sur
tous les états soient qui sont hésitants
soit qu'ils refusent certains refusent
des systèmes de protection sociale pour
les travailleurs ceci dit on peut aussi
constater que face à cette pandémie
une centaine de pays ont dû prendre des
mesures d'urgence parce qu'ils n'avaient
pas système de protection sociale et qui
à un moment donné vous ne pouvez pas
laisser une population complètement
démunis
sauf quelques personnalités complètement
obtus citerai personne
dont vous êtes obligés de réagir donc il
a fallu improviser des mesures de
soutien mais ça reste de l'improvisation
et ça reste d'une efficacité qui n'a
rien à voir naturellement avec un
système qui est organisé alors vous
soulever la question du financement ça
c'est un débat qui est tout à fait
légitime mais de ce point de vue là il
peut y avoir de multiples approches
c'est vrai dans le domaine politique
mais c'est vrai sur le champ syndical il
ya des suggestions pour considérer et je
pense qu'il y aurait moyen de faire
évoluer nos le les modalités de
financement du système de protection
sociale mais ça n'est pas parce que il
faut débattre sur l'actualisation des
modalités de financement que pour autant
il faille
comment dire disqualifier le principe et
le système lui-même là ce serait bon
-aux franchi un autre un autre un autre
cap
alors oui les questions liées à la
finalité du travail elles vont être
elles vont être de plus elles sont de
plus en plus moi je constate par mes
rencontres mais vous aussi sans doute
je pense que les jeunes générations et
c'est une bonne chose nous pousserons de
plus en plus et pousseront les
entreprises elle le pousse elle pousse
déjà les entreprises à se justifier sur
la finalité du travail et vous avez
aujourd'hui des jeunes à qui il arrive
s'ils en ont la capacité matérielle je
dirais mais de refuser certains emplois
au motif qu' il considère ce qu'on va
leur demander de faire est contraire à
la vision qu'ils peuvent avoir de la
finalité du travail ou au contraire à
une certaine éthique et je pense que
c'est une très bonne chose
et d'ailleurs il n'ya qu'à voir combien
les entreprises sont de plus en plus
contraintes de travailler leur image
auprès du grand public sur leur
comportement sur la manière dont elle
traite aussi les salariés
pour pour comprendre que ça a un impact
y compris sur des sur des nouvelles
générations
et puis je l'évoqué je n'y reviens pas
mais la question environnementale de de
fait pose la question de la finalité du
travail on ne peut plus produire comme
avant on ne peut plus commercer comme
avant est toute la question va être
enfin la question la question c'est de
définir de nouvelles réponses
et ça ça ne peut pas être uniquement une
logique économique qui l'emportent ça ne
peut pas être uniquement un cercle
d'experts qui le décide
je pense qu'il ya une capacité réelle de
ceux qui travaillent qui ont de
l'expérience professionnelle d'apporter
leur pierre à la réflexion ça ne veut
pas dire que ce sont eux et eux seuls
qui vont pouvoir le définir évidemment
mais ils ont une certaine expertise leur
niveau il faut absolument le reconnaître
ce droit à pouvoir intervenir à proposer
à suggérer de nouvelles orientations
donc est ce sera je le pense aussi
susceptible de nous aider à trouver des
réponses différentes pour la
préservation de la planète
alors je reviens pas sur la réflexion de
monsieur guay sur le financement de la
protection sociale je viens de le
révoquer
oui on est et le débat autour des du
statut des personnels utilisés dans les
plateformes qui illustre pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux un jeu revient au
début de l'ue propose cette liberté
soupçonnée que coffret les plateformes
à l'usagé les personnes aujourd'hui sont
les plus nombreuses il n'y a qu'à voir
la constitution ça surprend certains
observateurs mais maintenant la
constitution de syndicats de deux
salariés de ces plateformes face à la
loterie mais d'utilisateurs de ces
plateformes qui revendique désormais la
reconnaissance de droits sociaux est en
tout cas qui se retrouve complètement
démuni en matière de protection sociale
alors c'est que ça peut renvoyer à
d'autres à d'autres débats lors de la
création de la sécurité sociale
certains certains acteurs de l'économie
n'ont pas souhaité rejoindre le système
collectif de sécurité sociale des profs
des professions indépendantes des
professions libérales
c'est un choix historique faut-il revoir
ce
ce dispositif d'ensemble pourquoi pas
mais ça ça ça recouvre un débat plus
large avec l'ensemble des acteurs et de
leurs représentants pour après tout le
périmètre de la sécurité sociale a été
un accord à un moment donné doit-il
recouvrir une notion plus universel
s'agissant du travail en france
mais je rappelle que dans certains
secteurs professionnels et je crois que
c'est encore le cas c'est pas du tout la
proche bon et donc moi je suis assez
critique sur cette idée que dans
certains secteurs on peut refuser
l'apport aux biens publics en termes de
cotisations de financement à la sécurité
sociale et refusant sac quand on est en
difficulté on en appelle à la solidarité
nationale présents oui parce que la
sécurité des nations unies une
obligation pour les salariés c'est le
choix de consacrer une part de la
reconnaissance de son travail non pas en
rémunération directe mais ce qu'on
appelle une rémunération enfin une
rétribution indirectes c'est-à-dire
qu'on s'est accordé pour qu'une part
soit reversée aux travailleurs non pas
sous forme de salaires directs mais sous
forme de cotisations pour financer son
système de protection sociale je
m'excuse peut-être d'avoir l'air de
faire un un cours élémentaire mais je
crois que de temps en temps il faut
aussi le rappeler vis-à-vis de ceux qui
s'interrogent c'est aussi le choix
historique qui a retenu un système qui
soit à la fois obligatoire non pas pour
restreindre la liberté de l'individu
mais pour qu'il soit pertinent et
efficace et y compris incarnant une
dimension solidarité nationale c'est une
autre des vertus de notre système que de
matérialiser une dimension de solidarité
lorsque l'individu est dans la
difficulté la peine la maladie ou
l'accident de travail par exemple
merci pour ces réponses donc ça ça
libère vraiment ono deux rapporteurs si
vous devez en urgence maintenant
rejoindre l'hémicycle
martin berthet peut-être pour continuer
au nom des rapporteurs
oui merci beaucoup président merci
monsieur donc pour les éléments que vous
nous apporte effectivement avec un point
de vue peut-être parfois différent de ce
que l'on a pu entendre en tout cas très
intéressant
j'aimerais vous poser donc plusieurs
questions tout d'abord sur le rôle de
l'aspect de l'inspection pardon du
travail le rôle actuel qui est un rôle
plutôt de sanctions
nous aimerions qu'ils soient tourner
plutôt vers un rôle de conseil notamment
vis-à-vis des nouveaux modes de travail
de management il et les évolutions que
nous constatons qu'elle est votre votre
opinion par rapport à cet aspect là
ensuite alors peut-être l'avez-vous
abordés mais je vois ça m'a échappé si
vous l'avez fait concernant la ppl santé
au travail actuellement en cours
d'examen par le parlement
pouvez-vous également nous donner votre
sentiment sur cette ppl est ce qu'elle
répond aux besoins et aux besoins
d'évolution
bien sûr on le voit les travailleurs des
plateformes sont concernés par cette
question de santé au travail
donc est ce que pour vous cette ppl y
répondent également par rapport aux
rapports foin et à la question de la
prise en charge la couverture sociale
des travailleurs des plateformes
sa proposition est plutôt sur un portage
salarial mais les travailleurs des
plateformes visiblement ne sont pas en
accord avec la plupart avec cette
proposition quel est votre avis je vous
remercie
allez-y merci monsieur le président
alors sur l'inspection du travail
l'inspection du travail vaut une
convention spécifique de l'oit et il ya
200 conventions internationales du
travail une la 182e de mémoire mais peu
importe la numérotation se consacre
exclusivement à la mission au rôle et à
l'organisation des services de
l'inspection du travail dans les états
ça n'est pas pour rien bon de ce point
de vue là je dirais qu'on a une
inspection du travail en france qui est
conforme à la convention internationale
du travail
c'est heureux ce qui n'empêche pas
parfois des litiges on l'a vu
dernièrement d'ailleurs
dans cette convention une des
caractéristiques importantes c'est il ya
tout un tas de considérants mais une des
caractéristiques importance
naturellement que l'inspection du
travail souhaite une structure
indépendante dans certains pays je pense
à des no tamment des pays d'asie mais
aussi mais aussi en afrique
une ministre d'un pays d'asie du travail
disait dans une assemblée de l'oit et
nous avons multiplié le nombre
d'inspecteurs du travail chez nous mais
aidez nous service de l'oit et à lutter
contre un phénomène que nous n'avons pas
résorbée c'est la corruption et pour
cause les inspecteurs trail nekkaz il
n'était quasiment pas payer aucun des
moyens d'éviter la corruption c'est
naturellement de faire en sorte de
garantir une indépendance aussi par une
une rémunération qui préserve de ce
phénomène de corruption dont
l'indépendance est sûre la mission la
mission
re internationale reconnue c'est une
mission de contrôle alors je sais parce
que c'est aussi un débat je dirais
régulier avec les employeurs quand la
nature du droit du travail à la nature
des soutiens je sais aussi que les les
entreprises souhaitent avoir du conseil
c'est pas forcément la mission les
inspecteurs ultra et moi je comprends
aussi que la complexification du droit
du travail mais la complexification du
droit du travail
c'est pas le contenu de ce droit qui est
en cause de mon point de vue c'est que
pardonnez moi cette remarque le
législateur s'est efforcé arraf
à chaque fois qu'un droit a été codifié
de multiplier la liste des soies des
dérogations ou des adaptations
nécessaires dans tel ou tel domaine
et quand vous avez ce débat public par
rapport à la consistance du code du
travail vous vous apercevrez que quand
dutra est proprement dit n'est pas si
épais que ça mais par contre ce sont
tous les chapitres exonérant des
secteurs et donc que les chefs
d'entreprise souhaitent eux mêmes comme
les syndicalistes je vous avouerai un
peu perdu quant à la nature du droit du
travail applicable à tel ou tel salarié
en fonction de tel ou telle situation de
telle taille d'entreprise en fonction de
la localisation de cette entreprise du
statut juridique de cette entreprise est
ce un sous-traitant et ce à tout le
monde et donc les entreprises réclament
du conseil mais ça ne veut pas dire pour
autant et encore une fois la demande
l'aspiration peut-être tout à fait
légitime ça ne veut pas dire pour autant
qu'il faille trouver la réponse chez le
corps des inspecteurs du travail qui eux
par définition sont là pour veiller à la
bonne application du droit alors il leur
arrive et ils le font très régulièrement
de conseillers pour autant les
entreprises
ils l'ont fait d'ailleurs durant la
période de pandémie alors ils l'ont fait
au sens où ils ne sont pas là a priori
pour réprimer mais comme tout contrôleur
d'un droit à un moment donné si leur
apparaît que une entreprise délibérément
enfreint le droit le rôle de
l'inspecteur c'est aussi comme le ferait
un gendarme en bord de la rose s'il
estime qu'un conducteur être moi sous
mauvaise foi et à et a commis une
infraction importante de réprimer donc
c'est le rôle de ces le rôle de
l'instruction mais est très souvent
d'ailleurs il
il regrette pour tout vous dire
plusieurs choses a toujours la
problématique des effectifs suffisants
imaginez ce que ça représente
y compris pour eux l'impact des
nouvelles technologies et cette capacité
à contrôler la bonne exécution du droit
du travail une une des caractéristiques
de l'impact on n'a pas trop peu évoqués
jusqu'à présent nos gens dit un mot inde
un des impacts de cette nouvelle
technologie c'est que on dépasse aussi
les frontières
que ce soit les plateformes ce soit le
télétravail le télétravail vous ne
limitez pas télétravail à du personnel
qui est en fait aujourd'hui les
entreprises d'aujourd'hui font
télétravail et leur comptabilité en asie
lors leurs dessinateurs en amérique etc
etc
et ce n'est pas d'aujourd'hui que sur
des collectifs internationaux je dirais
de travail la question de l'application
le droit applicable dans ce contexte là
et alors c'est là qu'il ferait une
réponse à mon avis un peu plus adaptée
du droit international parce que là il
faudrait se mettre d'accord entre
différentes nations pour avoir un
standard comparables ou ce qui est loin
d'être loin d'être le cas alors sur les
deux autres questions pardonnez moi
elles sont un petit peu plus pointue sur
le ppl je vous avoue je n'y ai pas
regardé mais encore une fois je souhaite
que ce soit davantage les représentants
syndicaux en exercice qui soit habilité
à se prononcer sur des questions qui
nécessitent leur leur contribution leur
leur propre analyse et un suivi un peu
plus détaillée de l'évolution du droit
français
étant entendu que
si je demandais désintéresse pas du tout
bien évidemment mais j'en suis un peu
plus détaché depuis depuis quelques
années
[Musique]